let me read an article here about
because uh so so kurt you know the
comments right now are on fire about bsv
right
yeah so they love bsv apparently i mean
i'm being sarcastic so can you pull up
this article about what uh vitale had to
say uh uh
so uh uh yahoo article this is two years
old though this is not a new article
it's two years old ethereum's vitalik
materian slams bitcoin sv obviously a
complete scam if you can go up a little
bit ethereum vitalik maintained his
hard-line stance on bitcoin uh sv in a
recent interview colin craig craig
writes cryptocurrency complete scam
speaking with due to our government
a little room for interpretation
regarding his thoughts on bsv the
co-founder also gave his thoughts on
decentralized exchanges and the
warringly centralized accumulation of
power by uh binance go a little lower
obviously bsv is a complete scam but the
the listing from binance that was
interesting there's arguments in favor
of it but then there's also an argument
that this is a centralized exchange
that's wielding a lot of power
what do you have to say about his
thoughts against bsv
i mean we're
bsv makes ethereum completely obsolete
so i mentioned ethereum is good for 15
tsv makes ethereum completely up
completely ethereum is good for 15
transactions per second globally and it
does smart contracts that cost sometimes
800 a transaction just to make a wallet
or just to do all these different things
which would obviously concern our friend
vitalik there is there was no scaling
ceiling on bsvp but it was zero in
fairness ethereum was never intended to
be a transactable currency or an
investment it's you know what there are
if you go look at vitalik buterin quotes
from 2017 he was the one talking about
that it's a travesty that btc fees are
over five dollars or whatever oh no that
could never be disruptive and now you
know literally eight hundred dollars to
make an ethereum wallet if you're trying
to open a defy contract and it's it's
madness but on bsv you can do about a
hundred thousand transactions per second
today
full smart contracts everything that
ethereum can do can be done for an
infinitesimal fraction of the cost and
at exponentially higher speed than
ethereum and that's why bsv is a scam in
his opinion people don't want to hear it
the reason it's been delisted from
binance and from all these other places
is because the entire crypto economy all
10 000 of these block chains some days
bsv has more transactions on just bsv
than the entire rest of the blockchain
economy combined nobody talks about it
and it's because it's their ponzi scheme
they're making money by trading tokens
and by accruing this liquidity what bsv
does is not about crypto trading that's
not the thing here what it is is it is
disrupting the entire global economy we
don't want to replace the blockchain
economy we want to replace the internet
period do you think those blockchains
are going to consolidate at some point
they have to they don't work like they
literally need to bring whatever value
is on those blockchains needs to come to
bsv because the other blockchains don't
work they can't scale people don't get
it l2 all this layer two nonsense four
years ago ethereum's oh plasma's gonna
fix everything plasma never came out it
can't work elon moyes just came in so
he's in he's in the chat he's watching
the uh no no i'm being serious
so he came and he says bitcoin does the
work of a hundred thousand bankers per
second what does he mean by that
that it's everything bitcoin is bitcoin
isn't is a global notary it is a it is a
global group of bankers it is a global
uh data attestation service it is the
internet that's the thing everything you
can do if you want it's the deed you buy
a car with bitcoin and it is your deed
the coin is everything every single
piece of ownership identity and
transaction period can can happen on bsv
if if we were to move the entire global
economy to a blockchain today it would
have to be bsv it could not be done on
another blockchain period
so
chamath says 200 000 by the end of next
year what do you think
i think he's a madman i think i think
he's
here's the thing it could be if it if it
does it'll be because it's the it's the
inflation meme it's the problem
sure but he's been wrong before
yeah so back uh i don't think it'll be
that will primarily
if
if that's the case
if it's the case it'll be primarily an
indicator for how bad the economy has
gotten it will not be because of value
that was created
by the blockchain so it's a hedge
against it's a hedge against
hyperinflation it is the only thing that
people are using it for that's it are
you familiar with this bitcoin rainbow
no i don't think so you're not what is
it
okay i mean maybe maybe a different name
what are we talking about it's called
the bitcoin rainbow i don't think only
you would know something
let's hear it is it a gay pride thing no
i'm not saying that it's just like
bitcoin rainbow price you've got a
hundred questions to ask you're asking
my bitcoin rainbow because this is
essentially the predictor of what's
going to happen yes okay so what's it
telling us yeah yeah you've never seen
this i have seen this okay okay all of a
sudden i'm teaching you something
bitcoin guy bitcoin
rainbow says basically this is exactly
like it's sort of like the
the
teacher's manual this is insane tell me
why we shouldn't laugh at whoever made
this seriously like look at this what is
this i don't know but apparently it
works
no what it is is you overlay it on
something that exists like this didn't
exist 10 years ago somebody put this
together a couple years ago at the very
it was
any rational person should look at this
and laugh like what is it even telling
us
well i think we can all agree that the
word rational is a very loose
terminology these days with the
metaverse and the nfts and the bitcoins
none of this is rational bro that
indicates that we are in a bubble that
will crash okay let's talk about that
what's this bubble you hear the bitcoin
bubble the crypto bubble the dogecoin
bubble what's the bubble it's the same
reason people don't work at the at the
burger stand anymore either it's the
same reason there's supply shortages
everywhere it's the same reason we can't
get port workers to to unload
however a half a million ships or
whatever that are off the coast of
california it's because the entire
economy is broken the entire economy is
slowing down it is fundamentally
changing in ways that are not good okay
it's because people are being paid to be
lazy right and it's the exact same thing
they're doing with cryptocurrency they
look at it and they're like oh well i
mean you should buy this thing you may
never have to work again like buy shiba
inu coin and okay here it is and it's
like okay what does shiba do who is what
what economic utility is being unlocked
by shiba inu coin what do any of these
coins do for that matter nothing the
answer is nothing and that's the problem
are you basically predicting a crypto
crash
yes it's all nonsense
okay
well i mean you're the bitcoin guy so
like the fact that you're saying that
the fact that you're saying that crypto
is all nonsense alarm bells should be
going off right now
he so so
you have to know that if pomp was
sitting here right now we would have to
separate them because they have complete
opposite you know
pomp is a bitcoin loyalist right
and and he may be one of the best uh
explainers of bitcoin out there when i
listen to pom i say yeah i walk away
saying okay cool you know so his
position is a different position than a
pomp then a
there's a lot of again go back to the
religion civil war can you put up this
question somebody just asked i'm curious
to know what your thoughts are on this
and we're going to change the subject
and go into jack dorsey and a few other
guys and maybe we'll talk about uh some
more about this bitcoin rainbow but go
go to what i just sent you uh uh i know
if you see it or not try to try to get
it over just give me a second trying to
get it okay all right so anyways i'll
read it to you while he's trying to
figure this out tyler
so uh john pitts at equity diamonds i
don't know if you know who he is or not
i do okay you know who he is he asks
number one question how would bdo
an audit firm which relies on its
integrity minutes
which are independently produced csv has
no control
not be a smoking gun that csv equals sn
can you unpack that question for us and
then answer that then i got to follow up
second question for you this is strictly
for the bitcoin community yep how would
you respond to that so i've been in
court can you unpack his question by the
way this is from the the climate right
trial i have been it every single day
every single minute of this trial taking
notes and doing a live stream every
evening for it so uh there might not be
there's one other guy who who is
probably equally expertise on this and
it's my buddy pat but um there was a
piece of evidence admitted
my buddy pat thompson but that's my
buddy
craig wright gave a piece of evidence
that was minutes on bdo letterhead from
2007 this is about a year before the
bitcoin white paper came out and it was
explaining
uh time chain p2p cash system and and
giving a timeline of when he wants to do
these things and whether or not bdo
wants to invest in this idea and make it
a bdo product bitcoin as a commercial
essentially triple entry accounting
system which would be great for bdo in
theory okay but they didn't understand
the opportunity so
basically what it is is this is proof of
about a year before bitcoin released of
craig wright showing bdo what is
essentially bitcoin and explaining all
right we'll release the white paper in
q3 of 2008 we'll get the software done
and tested you know during this timeline
we'll try to release by early 2009
and uh and there's a guy named alan
granger who's some kind of executive at
bdo in australia basically signing off
on it and it was going to be
greenlighted except the economy
collapsed and ultimately uh research and
development projects and stuff ended up
getting booted in fact craig also got
let go from the bdo uh just a few months
later not for malfeasance but simply
because hey we're letting a bunch of
people go because of the economy so this
is why bitcoin became
satoshi nakamoto project instead of
bitcoin trademark of bdo product
so
um i i think it's a very compelling
piece of evidence i think it's a piece
of evidence that people were not
expecting and people want to write it
off and they're like oh it's a
handwritten note it could have come from
any time anywhere but it's well but it's
on bdo letterhead and and
and time stamped and all these things so
i think it's a major smoking gun a major
bombshell and another piece of evidence
of craig wright for which
i saw about a thousand pieces of
evidence that um that basically couldn't
point to anything else so to answer your
question from probably an hour ago why
craig right satoshi nakamoto if craig
wright is not satoshi nakamoto he's been
pretending to be since about two years
before bitcoin existed
and doing almost nothing else with his
time it just wouldn't make any he
wouldn't have time to do anything else
and so how'd you answer the second
question if bit cash bitcoin email from
2008 is indeed a fraud
as csv csv equals craig wright right csv
csw
how does klyman have a case at all i i
personally don't think climate has a
case at all it doesn't make sense to me
the the the whole thing is is predicated
on craig wright being a bad man and
trying to get money for the estate the
way that i see it i think it's a giant
moment anyone going to jail
no absolutely no
no
and also in a civil case though you
don't need all 12 jurors to agree it's
only it's you only need a majority and
fyi for the audience
let's listen to this a lot of people are
asking me about having john e deaton on
just so you know he's the founder of
crypto law dot us and uh he's a
lawyer
known in the crypto community we are
having conversations about having him on
the podcast and we'll talk about what's
going on with the case i know people are
asking about it him and i have started
communicating in the last week or so
we'll let you know when that does take
place so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you